ja willkommen zu einer instruktion wie
man philosophische hausarbeiten schreibt
genauer gesagt wie man sie formatiert
man formatiert hausarbeiten wenn man sie
geschrieben hat oder schon beim
schreiben kann man sie auch formatieren
wir beginnen mal mit dem titelblatt das
ist der anfang der hausarbeit und sie
sehen oben rechts kommt rechts bündig
formatieren wir den 13 die dozentin die
universität das semester und den
seminaren namen und auch noch das datum
der abgabe ganz unten links links bündig
kommt dann der name der verfasserin des
semesters kombination des studienfachs
matrikelnummer und e mail ist auch ganz
wichtig dann kommen wir schon zum titel
und zwar steht ein titel einer
hausarbeit immer aus einem obertitel und
einem untertitel und ich habe hier schon
mal einen artikel an gegeben aber dann
können wir jetzt noch ändern
wir können jetzt ein philosophischen
titel wählen der sollte immer so ein
bisschen prägnant formuliert seine
kürzer kanaren zitat sein als man könnte
jetzt zum beispiel mal schreiben wenn
wir uns in dem fach
im seminar theorien derzeit befinden
schichten derzeit
und das wäre jetzt der obertitel der ist
jetzt etwas portiert und untertitel
könnte man jetzt zb wählen
schellings theorie der geschichte das
wäre jetzt ein möglicher titel kann auch
den untertitel bisschen kleiner
formatieren schriftgröße 16 uhr nicht
fett machen
so könnte jetzt zum beispiel ein titel
aussehen untertitel
jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten punkt
nämlich zur formatierung der einzelnen
überschriften eine hausarbeit besteht
aus einleitung aus hauptteil und
ausschluss das heißt jetzt nicht dass
man die einleitung einleitung nennen
muss man kann auch stadt einleitung eine
frage aufwerfen
oder man kann danach hat doppelpunkt
machen und eine amerikanisierung der
einleitung geben aber normalerweise
genügt einleitung hauptteil kann man
ebenso einen anderen titel wählen aber
das macht nichts in den hauptteil haupt
seinen ebenso mit dem schluss die
einleitung sollte eben ganz portiert
eine leitfrage enthalten ein leitfrage
oder einen leid problem
und die sollte also spezifisch sein
was interessiert sie im folgenden im
folgenden das ist die frage die sie hier
aufhören sollten und sie können
natürlich auch schon angeben wie sie
dann im hauptteil dieser leitfrage
behandelt werden also welche methode
wähle ich zur beantwortung der leiter
frage das kann natürlich auch mehrere
fragen seien im hauptteil sollte dann
diese leitfrage sehr differenziert
entwickelt werden und dazu kann es
sinnvoll sein den hauptteil inzwischen
schritten zu unterteilen also zum
beispiel 2.1 könnte man jetzt eine
überschrift geben
schillings hintergrund annahmen
eine generelle einführung dann 2.2
schillings theorie der zeit und 2.3
schillings theorie der geschichte
es werden drei mögliche schritte sehen
wir uns vom allgemeinen vom hintergrund
zum speziellen seine geschichte über den
begriff der zeit und dann am schluss ein
kommentiertes fazit vielleicht noch
einen ausblick was konnte nicht
behandelt werden
kurze zusammenfassung
die wichtigsten ergebnissen jetzt müssen
wir das natürlich auch formatieren das
heißt wir wollen ein automatisch
generiertes inhaltsverzeichnis am ende
haben und dazu wählen markieren wir die
überschrift einleitung und gehen dann im
bereich start zum bereich formatvorlagen
und wählen hier die formatvorlage
überschrift eins überschrift 1 meint
nicht dass die beschlüsse einst die
nummer eins trägt sein da sie auf der
ersten oder höchsten gliederung säbel
sich befindet die einleitung hauptteil
schluss wir vergeben diese formatvorlage
meistens ändert es dann von hause aus
die schriftart wir können dir wieder
zurückstellen auf times woman und
schriftgröße 12 und schwarz haben wir
die einleitung auf der ebene 1
formatiert eben so machen wir es mit dem
hauptteil da gehen wir auch auf die
überschrift 1 von martin ist zurück wir
können natürlich auch formatvorlagen
selbst definieren und genau so machen
dass schluss auch überschrift 1 hardheim
jetzt bleiben noch diese untergliederung
punktes haupthalle übrig die befinden
sich jetzt nicht mehr auf der ersten
ebene sind auf der zweiten weil wir
jetzt hier 2.1 2.2 2.3 sind weil sie
müssen ihn die formatvorlage überschrift
zwei zuweisen zu machen wir genauso
mit allen diesen drei überschriften
überschrift 2
und überschrift 2 ebenso zum punkt 2.3
jetzt können wir dann den inhalt schön
eingeben
der ist jetzt nicht mehr formatiert der
ist jetzt standarten formatiert und hier
genauso wir können hier eine neue seite
wählen das ganze etwas verteilen über
die zeiten hinweg
und nicht zu vergessen wir müssen
natürlich auch seitenzahlen einfügen
einfügen seitenzahl am seitenende
einfache zahlen und jetzt haben wir hier
eine hausarbeit mit 15 springen wir auf
die seite vor der einleitung das muss
noch ein bisschen zurücknehmen
die seite vor der einleitung
das heißt
machen hier eine kehrseite mit steuerung
und enter können wir eine leere seite
einführen und fügen jetzt an dieser
stelle
das inhaltsverzeichnis 1
dazu gehen wir auf verweise den reiter
verweise inhaltsverzeichnis automatische
tabelle und wir sehen wird oder dass
office programm hat uns jetzt ein
inhaltsverzeichnis generiert mit zwei
gliederung des ebenen auf der ersten
ebene finden sich einleitung hauptteil
und schluss und die untergliederung
punkte des haupt teils befinden sich ein
gerückt weil sie in der zweiten
führungsebene stehen wir sehen auch hier
schön die seitenzahlen die am rand
aktuell sind wenn wir jetzt eine zeit
etwas verschieben wird mit zwischendrin
mehr text produziert haben dann müssen
wir mit rechtsklick auf das
inhaltsverzeichnis dieses aktualisiert
und felder aktualisieren und gesamtes
verzeichnis aktualisieren wenn wir die
überschrift geändert haben ansonsten
wenn sich nur die zeiten zahlen jeder
tag geht auch die erste option wir
machen wir trotzdem die zweite und sie
sehen die seitenzahlen haben sich hier
angepasst das war's für heute